[Música]
[Aplausos]
ah
[Música]
no
hola soy el bien domínguez o bailarín
soy artista
yo considero que la vida o un proceso
creativo
y con esto
arriba cayendo indicada de repente en
curva y momento
está creado y lleno de nudos complejos
pero a la vez único
llegué a este pensamiento gracias a que
paralizar este
un día estando en mi casa aburrido me
propuse dibujar mis experiencias de vida
a manera de puntos en una hoja
las buenas las que volver a recordar por
las que más de aprendizaje
al ver mi hoja y todo un universo
conjunto y
para mí
juntos se forma un dibujo y así fue como
surgió la idea de crear esta pieza la
cual no llega
una idea plasmada no es consecuencia de
haber transitado un camino lineal a
vivir un proceso creativo debemos ser
conscientes de que podría llegar a ser
bastante
muy satisfactorio al experimento
creativo y con creatividad no eres lo
únicamente lo relacionado con el arte
está sirve para la resolución de
problemas de la vida diaria o en
cualquier profesión vivimos en un mundo
inventado
y ciudades dañadas por otros que llevan
mira a tu alrededor incluso lo que
comemos es producto final de las ideas
que surgieron de la mente de alguien más
somos un cúmulo de creaciones y así es
como vamos creciendo como
existimos porque imaginamos creas tu
vida a partir de la imaginación de la
soporte
aprovecha las quejas
este año ya es por sí solo un proceso
creativo la creatividad no es para unos
cuantos afortunados es parte de nosotros
de nuestra historia
es algo inherente al ser humano nacemos
con dicha cualidad
la cuestión es que es algo que se
desarrolla y se entrena sin consideras
que no la tienes creo que más bien nunca
te hayas puesto entrar en contacto con
ella o se fue cortando en el camino que
tanto te dejaba hacer tú mismo desde
pequeño
si pintamos las paredes y preguntamos
por qué las cosas
nos puedes limitando
cuando era pequeño mi hermano me mostró
una revista de arte y vi una técnica en
la que no
al colorear yo a limitarla me sentía muy
original así en la escuela pero me
regañaban que no era capaz de hacerlo
bien pues atrás pensaban que era
estúpida por colorear una vaca
de pequeño quizás no funcionan límites
creativos pero a medida que vamos
creciendo estos límites pueden venir tu
propia mente que tan creativo te deja
hacer cuando surgen imprevistos y se
cambian completamente tus planes que
tendrán tratas a lo que tienes a tus
recursos o simplemente cuando se trata
de generar
de buscar nuevas formas de divertirte y
aprender
tienes que estar dispuesto a correr
riesgos aceptar los errores llevar al
plan de acción ese cúmulo de ideas
también algunos ingredientes necesarios
para obtener el resultado que buscas son
la pasión y la dedicación así de esta
forma te sentirás bien y al final del
proceso lo habrás hecho por placer y no
buscan una aprobación somos seres
sociales y al final en mayor o menor
medida nos preocupa como nos verán los
demás y vengo a recordarte algo que ya
todos sabemos pero ponerlo en práctica
requiere valores
ser tú mismo tienes que vivir de acuerdo
a tus propias premisas sólo así habrá
creatividad esta es indicador de que hay
libertad personal
cada quien ve las cosas en base a sus
experiencias los juicios siempre van a
existir si haces buenos y no haces mal o
el típico mejor hubieras hecho esto
al final cada quien va cargando con su
persona
y me gusta esto por una experiencia que
tuve nuestra relación a la masa creativo
solo me sirvió para comprender como una
misma situación es analizada y entendida
de muchas formas en una ocasión estaba
solo en mi casa y tenía
una única tarea que era aprender el gol
y meter la mañana como soy humano y
cometo errores para que hacer la
realización de mi tarea y el boiler un
flamazo en la cara sólo me quedé sin
competencias de pestañas y cuando las
personas me preguntaban que me había
pasado al contarles recibir infinidad de
opiniones
y
que me fuera con una limpio para las
malas
por tanto el karma las opiniones
al origen de la existente eran muy
variadas y la verdad está una aparición
muy curioso y hasta cierto punto me
causó algo de gracia las personas las
hablan sus opiniones a veces sintió
pedirla y me di cuenta que eso pasa con
todas las decisiones que tomen o las
cosas que realicen tu obra tu idea y tu
vida siempre tendrían opiniones
distintas
nunca le vas a dar gusto a todos y al
final si te das cuenta que te están
deteniendo por el que van a decir estás
desperdiciando todo tu potencial en otro
caso si ustedes
creativa y original y quieren apoyarlo
sería bueno que este apoyo estuviera
libre de juicios porque los grandes
proyectos a veces surgen de ideas
considera inconcebibles
así que les compartiré
un hombre con una idea nueva
nuestra aparición de una idea de la nada
es la combinación ingeniosa de muchas
ideas y conocimientos adquiridos
previamente estudian prepárate investiga
y desarrolla tus habilidades
está tienen que estar a la altura del
desafío que estás enfrentando y esto
también incluye entre más tu lado
creativo considero que también incluye
que tanto te permites nutrientes de
otras personas diría que hay que estar
dispuesto a recibir lo mejor de los
demás para que tus ideas sean aún más
poderosas colaborar con otros cuyos
bancos de conocimientos son distintos
es una buena opción para complementar
tus ideas ya que no existen dos personas
con las mismas experiencias ni dos
cerebros iguales o puede ser que tú sea
sin complemente una idea que apenas ha
sido sembrada es normal que en el
proceso te parezca un poco frustrante el
no obtener respuesta rápidamente ya que
estamos acostumbrados a resolver las
cosas de una forma cómoda o ya conocida
y esto es señal de que estamos llegando
al límite de nuestra estabilidad
no esperes etiquetas a sembrar en tu
mente la cuestión
trabaja en ello muchas veces la
respuesta llegará cuando menos
incluso el sentimiento de espera
puedes llevarte a ser creativo la
imaginación es
durante todo el día tenemos la mente
ocupada por miles de tareas y tracks
ya sea trabajo escuela redes sociales es
capaz de todo eso aunque sea por un
momento considero es importante para tu
proceso creativo
para meditar el problema necesitamos
disponer de un espacio conocer
también podemos callar nuestro panteón
mental y este fue el interior que muchas
veces no aporta nada así podemos entrar
en contacto con una parte más profunda
de nosotros
sobre todo darte el permiso de entrenar
tu creatividad experimentar pequeños
juegos o procesos creativos diariamente
de qué forma podría ser creativo tu día
pequeños cambios con los mínimos que
sean sirven como forma de ejercitar tu
creatividad
hoy en día contamos con infinidad de
herramientas para poder
ideas y realizar
cuestiona todo cómo habrán inventado
esto cómo se hace qué significan qué
pasa si trata de encontrar respuestas no
necesariamente tienen que tener sentido
y coherencia de videos
fotos sale a poner improvisa imita algo
a alguien aquello que te aporte algo
positivo y que tengas
explora tus sentidos diviértete cambie
las reglas del juego
lo importante es tener la mente activa
la mayor parte del tiempo no tienes que
forzar la creatividad esta llegará solo
con el tiempo
tienes que estar atento a aquello que te
rodea para ello cuando encuentres algo
que pueda inspirarte que te agrade a
vibrar es importante almacenar apuntes
adjunta fotografías imágenes y tener
este cúmulo de ideas a la mano
así cuando esté trabajando en algún
proyecto podrás tener un banco de ideas
e irlas desarrollando visualiza prueba
puede que nuestros niños obstáculos y
sólo te queda improvisar tendrás que
tomar decisiones rápidas
con bien si al final nuestro resultado
que esperaba no tales fuentes de ellos
recuerda todo estamos en constante
aprendizaje y aún así anímate a
compartir
te compartiré la estrella de un centro
morelense muy creativo cuyo nombre no te
debe velar es para guardar su identidad
pero le diremos que hace años había un
concurso llamado el niño y la mar donde
el tema central era la mar y la
conciencia ecológica marítima en
cualquiera de sus diferentes
quiere hace siete años pensar en ganar
esa bicicleta y en baja a ver a cristo
preciado que tiene un espíritu muy
competitivo
a un niño
no tendrían muchas oportunidades de
salir
se sentía frustrado por no tener ideas
para realizar el dibujo y entonces llegó
al rescate de su hermano pintor artista
egresado del centro morelense de las
artes a decirle de cuántas maneras
diferentes puedes juntar dos ideas o
hacer algo más allá de lo obvio el mar
se verá diferente si lo ves desde dentro
como si fueras un peso si lo ves desde
arriba en un helicóptero si lo ves de
frente en la playa está limpio
de día de noche incluso si es la primera
vez que lo miras lucirá distinto cuando
lleves
qué materiales puedes combinar tienes
tus crayolas colores pinturas así pues y
ring realizó su obra más creativa
hermosa agraciada callada espléndida
suela maravillosa que pudo haber creado
jamás
después de una buena desvelada este
pero gracias distracción llegó muy
entusiasmado a la escuela con su papel
bond decidido por ese primer lugar
cuando de pronto notó que todos sus
compañeros changuitos tenían sus dibujos
en pequeños trozos de cartulina y que
creen que al final no bueno ni siquiera
apelaron su dibujo con aplicarse las
medidas específicas desde ahí aprendí la
elección digo la moraleja antes de crear
algo investiguen todas las reglas a
seguir para que no les pase como aquí el
bien recuerda al ser un creador no
siempre vas a tener libertad de hacer lo
que sé
tendrás situaciones donde habrá que
seguir ciertas normas si bien la
creatividad tiende a romper reglas y ser
algo rebelde esto no es sinónimo de ser
victorioso en todo momento
a lo que voy con este cuento que el
estético es que hoy en día cuando estoy
en medio de un proceso creativo me
planteo la idea de que las posibilidades
para resolver un problema son infinitas
y me reto a ver más allá de lo obvio
ahora también propone investigar las
especificaciones que requiere el
proyecto o idea
como dije anteriormente considero que la
investigación es una parte importante
cuando estás creando algo lo que sea que
desees que sea innovador funcional u
original la información es muy útil para
eso que estás creando responda a eso que
necesita
deja que la creatividad esté presente en
tu vida anímate a compartir algunos
otros talentos una vez me dijeron algo
que me hizo mucho sentido en su momento
cuando me daba inseguridad mostrar mis
ideas y es que merecemos compartir todo
lo que nos apasiona y luego en lo que
tenemos para aportar a veces tenemos la
creencia de que lo que ofrecemos no es
suficiente pero sí lo es el éxito no
está contenido en un tanque o en una
bodega puede que acercar y no te alcance
el éxito alcanza para todos siempre y
cuando esté dispuesto a pedirlo
abiertamente y trabajar por ello puedes
inspirar y se va haciendo una cadenita
una idea complementa la otra y así vamos
creciendo es lo mejor de todo esto
confía en que habrá gente que le dé su
valor que puede ser que su vida cambie
mucho poco pues
pero hacer las cosas cuando se te
ocurren porque después la magia de las
ciudades que puedes perder y no queremos
terminar con un baúl lleno de buenas
ideas que nunca
qué vas a aportar tú necesitamos de tu
ingenio lo bello y lo creativo para
recordar más que vale la pena pasar por
esta vida